this is Startalk hi it's Emily rice here
some of you might know me as DJ Carly
Sagan but in real life I'm professor of
astronomy and astrophysics at the CUNY
College of Staten Island as well as a
resource associate at the American
Museum of Natural History where our
benevolent / hosts our benevolent
overlord is the director of the Hayden
Planetarium but this is Startalk
Allstars I'm your all-star host tonight
and I have with me in the studio my
comedic co-host Chuck nice yes Emily of
course how are you how are you doing
great and I should and I purposely saved
this for the moment in front of our
listeners to ask you about your
beautiful new bundle of joy thank you
yeah the last time I recorded I was just
about just like how's he doing oh he's
amazing he's just fantastic this is your
first child too right yeah are you
sleeping yet no you don't mind because
this is your first child yeah it's like
everything is magical and wonderful yeah
I now see I'm on my third child and
that's when you just don't give a damn
but anyway enough of that
congratulations thank you and we should
introduce our guest this episode of
Allstars we're going to delve into one
of the hottest stories of the year the
discovery of the Trappist one system and
it's seven exoplanets to help us with
that we've got a very special guest
today
David kipping who is a professor of
astronomy at Columbia University hey
greetings to you start talk without
they're across the space-time continuum
wherever and whenever you are talking to
an amateur here so you're a research
astronomer we'll get to that but you
have your own YouTube channel right
that's right yeah we we have a youtube
channel called cool worlds the cool
worlds lab that's the name my group yeah
Columbia University and we do like a
vlog style
a few minute five minute videos once a
week roughly where we talk about you
know
papers we've been working on or just
cool ideas that are happening in the
field of exoplanets that's cool that is
very like I'm proud of my research group
I'll plug them BD n YC we have a logo
that's the subway actually let me do
this for the video watchers at home for
a start all actually it's the actually
there's a great yeah it's the actual
subway about the white because there
there's a why that's red but there's no
white rain there's no red white rain but
there for a little while there was no so
we study objects called brown dwarfs and
there was no y class of brown dwarfs but
we were looking for them and so we had
this joke going about there's no white
raining there's no white dwarfs now the
Y doors are discovered and so they've
ruined our joke right there's white
dwarfs which we'll talk about in a
minute probably when we get to the
science topic of today's show but no
white rain but you guys do you guys have
a logo for cool world's we not really we
have sat everybody's Saturn we know the
slick as you but I don't think you had
so didn't you not have like some problem
with like the new yorker subway service
were like hey that's our logo like cool
kids and i'm sure that you have quite a
following for those of you who don't
have the benefit of watching us on video
david looks like he could be in kind of
like an indie rock band like you know he
looks like the lead singer of like a
really cool hippie rock wish my wife
said the same thing between like hipster
and nerd it really is because like I
look at you and I'm like oh here's a guy
who is clearly a professor at Columbia
or he's importing I'm not importing but
selling locally sourced coffee in
Brooklyn
one point there was one you know one of
those those those internet games where
you play like is this a can I say this
is this a family show is it's a porn
star name or my little pony name like
really one of the things where it's like
you had to guess like which you know was
it a porn star name or my little pony
name okay there was also like is this a
homeless person or or a science
professor oh really I'm glad that's what
you think this was like way back in the
beginning of the Internet
no it's like oh is this is this a
science hipster or there's this a
scientist or a Brooklyn hipster very
cool goodie rocker or astronomer I just
like them I can't get over the porn star
my little pony that's the thing you
never heard about this
did I I was the one that spent too much
time on the Internet yeah talk about
today let's it we're gonna get to some
stuff oh yes sorry for the extended
intro but that was still fun before we
take our first cosmic queries let's take
a second to talk about exoplanets this
is your research area of expertise right
David this is a pretty epic discovery
kind of hit all of us at the blue we'd
only just recovered from the news of
Proxima Centauri having an earth-mass
planet around it and then this discovery
sort of not just goes one better but
seven better has seven so we knew about
this planet the this star in the and
some of these planets beforehand right
yeah that's right there was I think two
of them were had had the orbital periods
they knew that those plants were then
there was a hint of a third signal in
there and then they got some time on
nasa's spitzer space telescope and they
observed the star continuously for i
think of something like 500 hours which
was a lot of times a lot of times and
they saw like just transits everywhere
in this static it's just full of
transiting system so we know that these
planets are there why so what's
happening is there's a there's each of
these seven planets is passing in front
of the star blocking out some of the
light for a short amount of time and
it's happening periodically so the
orbital periods of these planets their
year is very very short compared to the
earth's 365 days these planets are more
like sort of one day up to maybe two
weeks and so every couple of weeks
you're seeing like a bunch of these
planets pass in front of the star and
loads and loads of dips all over the
place when you look at the brightness
over times that's how they found these
things
awesome and you study exoplanets right
that's right yeah and if exoplanets do
you study do you study these types of
exoplanets are different Wang sorts I I
don't discriminate oh I guess we
particularly like planets which we call
cool words which we really mean not just
like dope we're not like twenties in a
sense we mean like worlds which are at
long periods where they are cool enough
that they could be you know potentially
hospitable for life right we don't want
this super super hot one so much but
they're also kind of interesting
literally cool like literally constantly
exactly and we like the worlds which are
foreigner from this start there kind of
rings they can have moons they're gonna
be all sorts of extra stuff happening
start with are already fascinating I
love it and let's get into our queries
of course we have taken these questions
from all across the internet wherever we
have a presence and we always start with
a patreon patron because they give us
money so we say thank you don't come for
free that's right and we will give you
priority in terms of your query and what
I'm really saying to you people is we
can be bought we can be bought and we
are cheap here's the first question and
it comes from Frank Cain and Frank Cain
says this I've heard that Trappist ones
exoplanets are tidally locked to their
star how do we know that and what does
that mean for their suitability for life
and Frank comes to us from Orlando
Florida and that's a great question
Frank an excellent question
that's a great question yeah a lot of
people have been asking that as well
right we we actually don't know for sure
that they are tidally locked servation
exactly so and just for me as a
layperson
when you say that that observation would
be like our moon exact to the earth that
we can observe that the moon is actually
tidally locked and the assumption is
this is bad for life because you have
one side of the planet maybe like the
Americans
for example on the earth constantly
facing the Sun all the time like they're
all the way through ran its orbit and
the other side might you know freeze out
cuz it's going to be so cold so this is
the dilemma that you know if you have a
tire locked planet maybe it's not so
good for life in this case so the reason
why we think they probably are tightly
locked is that if you simulate the the
planetary system on a computer you let
them all the planets be freely rotating
you give them random rotation periods
this is what actually did in the paper
they simulated their orbits and they
found that within 400 million years
which sounds like a lot but other cosmic
timescale is not that much adlai are all
locked it doesn't take that long for
them to lock so within you know a cosmic
blink of an eye no matter how fast they
initially start spinning they're gonna
end up tightly locked pretty quickly so
that's why we think they probably are
but we don't have do it proof that they
are why do they end up tidally locked
yes so this is interaction between the
the star and the planet basically so
what's happening is as the star as the
planet is rotating round its it has a
slight tidal bulge from the from the
gravity of the star so the gravity that
starts kind of making it's like a squash
ball it's squashing the planets down
into these little ellipsoids and as it
rotates yeah same thing as it rotates
round one side of this ellipsoid is a
little bit closer and one sides a little
bit further away from the star and the
Stars kind of pulling on the near side a
bit harder so it's actually removing
angular momentum off the off the planet
it's literally not literally but it
would be it's it's it's like a braking
system for a planet a braking system for
a plan braking yeah that's amazing yeah
wow that's super cool and so the
implications for life would be like you
said because you yeah so and this is I'm
just gonna add to your question Frank
because I I've wondered this when you
have a tidally locked planet like this
and let's say that it's in the
Goldilocks zone is it possible and this
is just from my imagination that there
might be a strip a stripe throughout the
sphere of the planet
where that is the only place where you
have habitable life yeah that's actually
they call that the Terminator which is a
cool name we caught on the moon I think
this is actually a Jeopardy question the
other way this is how you can tell them
a new fan no parent is that my husband
and I watched jeopardy now before
bedtime it's fantastic it's not real
fortune so the term the terminators not
the bringer of death it's the bringer of
life in this case potentially on the
moon but the terminator on the moon
shifts right because the we have the
moon is tidally locked that was a great
example it was chalked right moon is
locked on us but this sunlight is coming
from the Sun the Starlight is coming
from the Sun instead of from the earth
right and so we can kind of think about
the moon when we think about these
planets but not really because there's
the the moon the Terminator moves around
the moon that would be moving but with
these planets the Terminator stays put
will be stationed yeah so there is no
Dark Side of the Moon I always like to
tell my students that think Freud lied
to you there's no dark side of Moon but
for these Trappist planets there is a
dark side of these planets
that's actually why moons could be
better places we'll come to remind me
yeah The Terminator would be like
perpetual sunset yes sunrise or sit
doesn't matter because it's not changing
right oh man that's so cool kind of cool
it is really really cool I wouldn't mind
living in the Terminator so I would my
retiring there let's move on to another
question this is Nick morrow and it
comes to us from Facebook and says this
is it correct that red dwarfs such as
Trappist 1 are assumed to persist for
trillions of years much longer than the
lifespan of our own Sun now that that
sounds pretty cool I've never heard that
before but I can only imagine that it
sounds like it's better to burn out than
the fade away so do fade away so this is
I love the people like the the our star
shark listeners know to ask
about the star because this is also
something different about these planets
then kind of a lot of the other planets
that we found before right so do you kid
do you care about the star that you find
your exit planets around or no I mean
these stars as exapilot anima s' love
finding planets around these particular
types of stars because it's so much
easier for us so this this star is
actually about one-tenth the size of the
Sun it's a really really small star okay
if you made it any smaller it would be a
brown dwarf it actually it wouldn't be a
star in the super nerds among you it's
an m8 an m8 if you know the spectral
types or AF g/km did I do that right Oba
fgk Ana yeah LT why the the LT why are
the brown dwarfs right officially but
really we don't really know where the
the the kind of boundary is but the LT
why the brown dwarfs and so the Y is the
coolest class but the M is really the
coolest class of stars right it's a
pitiful and correct you there
coolest class would be lbgtq I'm just
sayin I gotta get I get did I plug
everything now I think I did what else
do I have
alright the stars this star should as
far as we know live for trillions of
years of course we don't it's a similar
case we'd actually know that for sure
because the universe hasn't lived
spontaneously we were talking earlier I
think before we started about the the
what would you got the the delusions of
comedians yes just to let you guys in
before the show we were talking about
how comedians persist at being comedians
and I think it's because when they're
failing in the beginning there's a
delicate mixture of delusion and
narcissism that that drives them I
really feel like scientists are the same
way like we a lot we just have to stick
with it and persist right but also the
delusions I mean you know we can sit
here on a you know Saturday knowing that
we're gonna live for a hundred years if
we're lucky and talk about the universe
trillions of years from now with
complete confidence and let me just
share something is
like it keeps me awake at night about
these small stars Oh No
and that's that why don't we live around
one that's it kind of bothers me because
they actually make up the majority of
stars really this is 75% of all stars in
the universe are these types of stars
these M dwarf stars that's kind of we're
already the freaks of the universe Wow
next up we're not supposed to be special
this is the weird thing this is what is
it it's the Copernican principle we're
supposed to be special as observers
we shouldn't be special and it's kind of
been proven time and time again the
earth isn't the center of the solar
system the Sun isn't the middle of the
galaxy right lots of stars like the Sun
now we're finding there's lots of
earth-like planets but we seem to be
different we haven't found a lot of
earth-like planets around sun-like stars
they have way more earth sized planets
than the stomach stars do as far as we
can tell right now and they live for so
much longer it's like what gives like
how you know everything's working in
their favor it's kind of a mystery it's
in case you're worried about the Sun
burning out in five billion right
exactly not an issue for a nebula
well if so we can maybe you know a
couple minutes we can get to the
habitability I bet we have a question oh
god yes of course everybody of course
everyone wants to know about
habitability but before we get to that
well you know let's talk about along
that vein
we'll go with Neil Joyner and so we
won't get into habitability but we'll
talk about the likelihood of finding
intelligent life on one of these planets
in our lifetime you know life time would
be the operative phrase in the question
that's an interesting it's a I guess
it's almost impossible to predict when
we will learn the answer to that
question so I mean it could actually say
when you say when and not if yeah yeah
maybe a convolution of the two a little
bit but we could position I guess my
boys we could wake up tomorrow and SETI
has discovered because they are
listening right now in their listening
especially to these types of stars where
he's discovering these earth sized
planets you could hear tomorrow they've
discovered a signal but it could be you
know thousands upon thousands of years
of listening before in here anything
we've actually only surveyed such a tiny
tiny tiny tiny fraction there the signal
may still be coming to us
signal may be there but it may not
arrive in our lifetime or it may not
arrive in the time of human beings we
may be extinct from the planet anything
else is that that's what keeps me up at
night as we live i this is a we live in
the flicker that's I feel like that's a
TS Eliot or something like that that I'm
stealing from but like we live in such a
brief instant in the history of the
universe that you know there could have
been these amazing civilizations that's
a you know Star Wars a long time ago in
a galaxy far far away maybe that was our
real what if it is and we've missed it
let's take a little break and then we'll
come back with more after the break
welcome back to star talk Allstars I'm
your host Emily rice co-hosting with me
today is Chuck nice Hey and we also have
in the studio with us today
astrophysicist David kipping greetings
to where you start talk was out there
across the space-time continuum thanks
so much for having me here I'm really
excited to talk about a matter of really
cosmic importance today yes definitely
so we're talking about exoplanets
especially the Trappist one system
mm-hmm what are we so we talked about a
little bit about the star we talked a
little bit about the habitability of
these planets well well so we did talk
about the lifetime of the star right now
we had the because it's around an M
dwarf star it's not very different from
a sun-like star right and so what but is
how different is it so it's a lower mass
it's it's a smaller radius it's cooler
right but what does that mean for the
exoplanet yeah so I could guess maybe
another way of saying that question is
like other problems for potentially
people whole life stars live for a very
long time
yeah because they spend a very long time
fusing energy or fusing hydrogen to
helium heating energy I think there are
I mean everything happens in slow motion
for these stars right so actually you
know the Sun settle down into a fairly
normal star after it was born within
like 100 million years which is very
very fast for these M dwarf stars it
tends to happen like over one to two
billion years so these these planets
would have been receiving way
more radiation than the earth received
for a very prolonged period of time so
even though these plants are in the
habitable zone right now even you know
all three of them they would have been
being baked and you know maybe that
sterilized them for a gig a year that's
a billion years that's a long time that
they were being baked for right because
we've had life on Earth not well not
complex life on Earth but life on Earth
is existed for most of the history of
the solar system right they get
something like billions of years like
the life on Earth actually started very
very quickly after the Sun was formed it
happened almost immediately after the
heavy bombardment stopped which is when
the earth was basically pummeled by
meteorites and asteroids and the moon
had just formed and more as soon as the
earth became hospitable life pretty much
appears like straight away so that's
kind of exciting it is and but that so
what you're saying though is after being
in a microwave oven for a million years
the hot pocket might be just the so so I
study the M dwarfs I'm gonna say that
like and pitch my research again a
little bit because we my group studies
the brown dwarfs but we also study the
some of the lower mass stars and for a
long time people I don't want to say
didn't care but like kind of didn't care
a little like you know really when I was
pump applying for grants and you know
applying for jobs and stuff like that I
had to spin it a little bit I had to say
you know well these stars are important
for exoplanets because X Y & Z but now
like they really are like you know at
first everybody was going but after the
exit planets around sun-like stars which
was you know the last 20 years or so but
planets around these low mass stars has
only happened for the last these are the
sexiest time it was like oh you know
somebody's got to study them I guess and
now it's like oh you're in the best
place right yeah I want to tell you that
we do not understand these stars very
well that's true there's a lot about
them that we don't know yeah speaking of
job security you may not want to tell
people that
well that is why should we get into
another query yeah because we have Arun
Kumar from Facebook and Arun says this
what are this what are the chances that
this system has an asteroid belt like
our own what an asteroid belt even cause
sufficient dimming of the host star when
observing from 40 light years away just
speculating given that the planets
orbits so close together wouldnt that
have caused a lot of exchange material
collisions during the early solar system
formation and thereby creating an
asteroid belt okay Arun really knows how
to write a question can I say eight you
can write eight questions all right so
first let's just let's talk about the
asteroid belt is there a possibility
sure there's a possibility we don't know
about one yet the outermost planet
discovered in this system that she lives
beyond what we call the snow line so the
snow line is the distance from the Sun
at least in the solar system which water
ices and ammonia Isis and other ices
start to condense and they become sort
of solid grains the reason why we think
that's an important distance is beyond
that that's where you start to form gas
giants like Jupiter like Saturn so you
need to be beyond that distance now what
we find is that in the solar system in
between the last rocky planet Mars and
the first gas giant planet is the
snowline and right bang on there is the
asteroid belt the idea is that you know
Jupiter was migrating in when it was
forming it was moving around a lot and
it came in actually probably stopped
Mars from growing into a super Earth
Mars probably would have gone to a super
earth was it not for the influence the
super earth a super earth is like you
know add on twice the amount of mass
that the earth has just like just a
bigger earth and mars is kind of small
not only that but it probably stopped
another planet from forming which was
what the asteroid belt may have
coalesced to was it not for the
influence of Jupiter migrating in so
closed so I think the asteroid boat is
closed
they tied to what Jupiter did early on
the solar system okay we don't know
about any Jupiter's around the star and
it's actually very rare that these stars
even have jupiter-mass planets so it's
not I would my bet would be no but find
out do we have the technology to find
out if there's an asteroid belt around a
star light so good question it would be
super hard right now I mean even
detecting these planets which are like
70% the size of the earth that's big
compared to an asteroid which is like a
few kilometers across even that's like
really really pushing the spitzer space
telescope it was it was a you know a
tough discovery for spitzer and k2 to
get those so an asteroid belt i would be
skeptical we could do it with anything
we have right now that's for sure it
would have to be so sometimes we find
asteroid belts not because they block
light from the star but because they
radiate their own heat but that for that
to happen the asteroid belt has to be
close enough in that it has to be pretty
warm and then reradiates which I think
for this star is gonna be very close in
and we don't find that it's usually
called an infrared excess and there's no
space right I mean that it's a packed
planetary system there's no room yeah
every single slot is taken alright each
planet is the h planet outside of the
orbit of mercury relative to the Sun or
the H planet is even inside I I'm not
sure exactly spatially but I know it's
temperature is something like and maybe
minus 100 degrees Celsius or something
it's a cold because the star is so cool
everything is still packed really close
in there actually this brings up a
discussion that I actually saw other
astronomers having on Twitter which is
to think about what the planets would
look like from other planets like
sitting on one planet like sitting on
say D or E or one of the habitable ones
in seeing the other planets in your sky
they'd be huge because they're so close
yeah because they're so close to one
another right be bigger than the moon
yeah I think bigger than the moon
because everything is so close to one
another but then you'd also have to
think about every single one of them is
tidally locked and so you'd see
different phases depending on where they
are relative to you and you'd only see
them it you know you'd have to look
you'd have to be sitting at the
Terminator and see
you know so you might only be able to
see the exterior ones it's a great light
kind of solar system visualization
problem just to imagine but there should
be sci-fi yeah about this and I I just
have a feeling that we're gonna see a
blacklight poster of that at any time
okay here we go now we get to this is
for those of you who listen to the show
off and you know that I really suck at
pronouncing names
listen routinely you know I really suck
thank you good that was my closer hey
I'm Chuck nice I suck
alright so I believe this is tour or
tour a ball Hajj okay right okay and
look at me I'm like looking for approval
right no here we go this is what Torah
or Torah says if we were to send a radio
signal to that planetary system using
the radio hardware that we currently
have for the most advanced that we
currently have would the signal be
powerful enough for a potential alien
civilization to detect it assuming that
they are at the same technological level
as we that's a really good question and
if it was a directed purposeful radio
signal without doing the form
calculation which I probably should do
my I want to say yes to that to that
yeah I know for sure that our own
leakage so we produce you know just
radio waves from television signals and
radio shows like we used to but even
still there's still some leakage we
could not detect that if you know if
even if it was on the nearest star
Proxima Centauri at Alpha Centauri we
could not detect leakage from somewhere
that largest arrays right now
maybe the next generation the SKA might
be up for it which is being built right
now okay right now even the even the
nearest star and this isn't the nearest
star the whole idea of an alien
civilization picking up our television
broadcasts and that's how they know
about our society and who they are yeah
it's like that's the whole that's that's
never gonna happen well they could do if
they had much better radio receivers
than this they were building
planet-sized radio receivers then sure
they could detect us okay which is not I
mean we have planet so it's like a Death
Star for good we built a Death Star you
know but it's not far-fetched to think
of a civilization with more
technologically advanced systems than
ours right like yes we're hoping that's
why we push forward and maybe this other
stars had trillions of years well no you
know it's more billions of years than
we've had to push forward right yeah I
don't know I just want to stay
optimistic a little bit well super
bummed to hear that they're not
listening to like our old I Love Lucy
fascinated by listening to a radio show
okay well that's a very cool thing
so let's um let's move on - well Nylund
and will comes to us from sounds like a
pseudonym will Knightley very close to
Bill Nyes yeah almost coming to us from
Facebook and he says this if NASA's
budget doesn't increase what NASA have
to partner with private companies to
co-fund
getting us to any where we have to go is
this a door to a new space race okay so
I mean he's looking at it from both the
optimistic and the realistic standpoint
it's saying because you know from what I
understand not only is NASA's budget
going to be cut under our current
administration but NASA now owes they
have to pay back
[Laughter]
my gosh getting really nervous oh you
know what's funny is that the current
climate in which we live oh my god NASA
just got a bill oh my god we owe the
government money so but shut it down
when it comes to leading our solar
system now if we're ever gonna do that
or forget leaving our solar system let's
let's talk about is it really is it
really something that's going to be a
public-private partnership if it's ever
going to happen yeah I mean it has I
think this is a big misconception about
NASA is that it's really always been a
public-private partnership like you've
always had you know defense contractors
like Lockheed Martin and you know
companies making the Rockets it wasn't
always like purely NASA but it's just
become more out in the open now with
like SpaceX and and things like that
it's like kind of NASA has less of a
stranglehold on like the cool-looking
stuff to me like the you know the
contractor become the the agency's a
little bit the the the student has
become the master almost so now let me
follow up with with Will's question just
because so like you're wearing necklace
with the honeycomb
yes that's those are the mirrors right
for the James Webb telescope
yes for the video watchers printed like
and I wore this especially for today it
goes to the topic as I'm sure Bolton
well we always talk about JWST and very
soon you'll be able to get these in the
star talk store okay because these are
made by actually an engineering student
I think she graduated just last semester
3d printed designed by myself in summer
ash as part of Sartorialist a little
collaboration but it's a 3d printed
version of the James Webb Space
Telescope segmented mirror that is built
to the coolest things that this exists
now in Goddard Space Flight Center being
tested it's put on
the telescope and it's gonna go into
space very very soon
it's a NASA it's actually a promise to
be a partnership between NASA yeah
that's what that's my that's where I was
you know but it's definitely all kinds
of you know Lockheed Martin and Ball
Aerospace and you know there's tons and
tons of different contractors that build
parts of it so the the science
instruments are built by different
institutions some of the instruments are
definitely built by European centers
it's it's it's not like you know NASA
isn't the only one it's kind of NASA as
the umbrella the money kind of goes out
from okay all right well that makes
sense so there you have it so basically
the the the private the public-private
partnership already exists and it's just
a matter of how much deeper it will get
so that we can like how much we can see
behind the curtain a little bit I guess
a lot more than we used to be able to
see and I guess the real question is if
there's a way to monetize getting to
Mars or something like that so I mean it
to me that that's but for a whole entire
show a whole we can get into this to a
huge extent but for now we'll take a
break and we'll come back after a short
break to talk more about the Trappist
one and exoplanets when star talk All
Stars returns welcome back to star talk
all-stars I'm Emily rice your all-star
host for this evening and joining me is
my co-host Chuck nice we've been talking
about the Trappist one exoplanet system
with our special guest astrophysicist
david kipping hey and so before we go on
to our next segment of cosmic queries I
want to make sure that we talk about I
know I want to call it your your
moonshot a little bit intended because
this is my favorite thing about your
research which I follow you know all the
time but you want what do you want to
find you're not just looking for
exoplanets which let me back up have you
discovered any exoplanets I'm gonna
subject you the same question that I get
every holiday family gather yeah I guess
I guess I have I've only been on papers
which have discovered new planets and I
have a could turn either way I could say
yeah but only like half a dozen
you can't hear me rolling my eyes and
that mics are really good but I only
discovered six planets what are their
names I'm not super interested in these
planets that much because like one other
thing was happy 24 another one I've
always HD 80606 there was why do you
don't remember ones but they have
horrible names why do they do that I
don't think they I mean honestly you
know I mean when you look at the planets
in our solar system they've got cool
names you know I mean I know they're all
you know they they come from mythology
and stuff like that but George George
yeah Uranus was almost named with a new
render turned up to Uranus I'm pretty
sure was almost named George
oh man and you know what all right would
have been cool because from what I
understand George is a butthole YouTube
Ben wants me to plug Neil Tyson's
Twitter feed which he doesn't need my
help and but um I want everybody to
Google on YouTube
don't call me Collin because I want to
give a shout out to a colleague of mine
Neil Deacon who wrote a song about
naming exoplanets and this the the song
is called don't call me Collin and it's
adorable and it talks about how we named
we how we named almost named a planet
George at one point we were looking for
a planet within the orbit of mercury
that would have been called Vulcan
there's a whole history behind naming
exoplanets unfortunately for for us the
names of the planets usually are named
after the star and so and the stars have
kind of boring catalog names because
yeah yeah so HD HD is maybe even one of
the most interesting ones because it
means it was from the Henry Draper
catalog which is named after Henry
Draper who gave the money to the Harvard
College Observatory back in the day it
was like the early 1900s okay that's
interesting to me is that it was
actually I think he had already died but
his wife went to the observatory and
said you know find these stars named the
catalog after my husband here's a bunch
of money and a lot of that money
actually went to the women that did the
finding of these stars and study these
stars and
so they're called the Harvard College
computers because at the time the women
did like the computational work because
that was thought of as you know kind of
tedious work that required a woman's
touch like hidden figures right yeah
it's like it figures you know fifty
years earlier even and only white ladies
there's a lot of there's a lot of these
hidden figures and science that are kind
of coming out but so some of this so
Henry to HD the HD star that you
mentioned is from the Henry Draper
catalog hat h80
names like let's just if it's a super
interesting planet maybe that trap is
one let's maybe think about Trappist the
Trappist one is not bad I gotta say I'm
not I'm not I'm not mad at Trappist one
yeah HD I'm sorry do we know what
Trappist it's named oh it has it does
actually son this might be a weird so
it's the Belgian beer caps where some
letters are capital and some letters are
lowercase we do this in in astronomy
because we've kind of started to run out
of ideas and so we have to get really
creative so the bottom line is that
David doesn't care about the planets
that he's discovered because of them I
probably care more about looking for the
next thing about so what do you but you
so you you know you find exoplanets by
accident right but what do you really
want to find yeah so I guess the the
thing which has been married to my
career for a while now has been trying
to find the first moon around one of
these extrasolar planets I guess well so
far we haven't yet actually discovered a
like a candidate that we can all say
this is 100% an xme we have some
interesting things where are you looking
for these is there like a moon survey or
yeah yeah so we're yeah we are projects
called the hunt for EXO means with
Kepler which gives away what we're doing
so we're using archival Kepler data the
reason why Kepler is really the only
game in town for this is because you
have to have a very long baseline in
terms of time temporal coverage to do
this work so we're looking really for
like wobbles of planets and if you're
looking for a wobbling planet then you
have to have at least like three or four
transits of these plants and these
plants have to be quite far away from
their star
in order to have moons is there to pose
to the star the moons are gonna get
ripped off yeah exactly so you're in
you're kind of a rock you know bit stuck
between a hard place and that you have
to look at these long period planets but
those are the plants which you have the
least data for that's why it's it's hard
floor only has three and a half years of
data before there's a bit more than that
it's it's four and a third years but
including k2 no just just k1 original
[Laughter]
still the date for old Kepler exactly
say yeah the Kepler space telescope was
supposed to last for seven years I think
altogether after was it was proven
successful we kind of students funding
it's still very successful but the
original Kepler mission was supposed to
last for even longer than it did but one
of the reaction wheels failed to keep it
22 yeah two reaction wheels failed
leaving only two and then it had to be
repurposed in a very ingenious way it's
now called k2 I think we mentioned it
earlier in the show and it's it's but it
can't point in the same place where it
was pointing before and so it's kind of
starting to look at other places in the
nearby galactic neighborhood instead of
just the one place before and but this
is like this time baseline you said is
the important thing
yeah they Katie's looking at each field
for about three months that's not long
enough
for what we want to do so cap is really
the only game in town and it's kinda
press them because if we don't see
anything with a capital data we have to
wait a long time before someone's going
to launch a mission which is going to do
very long baseline like that again
probably Plato which is in 2024 by the
Europeans is the next thing in town
which is going to be usable that's
coming up even sooner they serve a
satellite is I'm super excited about
test but maybe not for memes so it's
it's looking at each field for just a
month and that's on the poles on it
actually has some overlaps so it kind of
looks all the way from the ecliptic you
know along where the the solar system
planets lie all the way up to the poles
and it looks all the way up in one go
kind of if you're online you can sort of
see you I'm doing my fingers but it kind
of looks like a strip from the equator
up to the North Pole and it moves along
and on that North Pole it actually is
continuous
so we get almost a year on the pole
I'm the year is not enough for me yeah
yeah so you gotta look far enough away
from the star what about for M dwarfs Oh
to be easier to find us yeah except them
doors don't have these these giant
planets
yeah that's there's always a problem
there's always a problem I was gonna say
so basically you just like being
frustrated yeah activating like that's
part of what I love like I love how
obvious it is like there's all kinds of
moons in our solar system but we haven't
found eggs a moons yet yeah and you will
and we did mention earlier about just to
come back to trap this morning you the
plants are all tightly locked to the
star right and that people have pointed
out you know that could be a bad thing
for life but one of the reasons I love
looking for moons is that they get
around that problem so even though as
you said there is in it the moon's tail
up to the earth but both sides of the
Moon get equal amounts of illumination
yes no such thing as the Dark Side of
the Moon
these movies are great but can we have a
tidally locked can we have a moon around
a tidally locked planet is there
anything the friends that they go so
that that may be where your life is well
guess what we are already down to that's
right the lightning round and so what
we're gonna do is read the questions and
they're a record for how many questions
have been answered and we can talk
really really fast no we're not that
machine Samuel Coe Harry wants to know
this could the system already be gone
because of destruction of its star
that's a hard no because Arden it's only
40 light years away so that means we're
only seeing the signals we're only
seeing the light from the star 40 years
ago 40 years is nothing this is do we
actually know the age of the star so we
know that the star lives for a very long
time but I don't think we actually know
the age of the star very well known as
Death Row's yeah and we don't think that
it's very young either so this is a part
of the discussion that I've been
listening to because I'm interested in
the star even more than the planet and I
don't think we think that it's a young
star so that means that it's probably at
least hundreds of millions if not
already billions of years old okay yeah
so 40 years is nothing for you know so
the answer is not likely at all there
what
yeah all right so pack your bags buddy
okay oh do you know we're after them
there we go
this is Martine who wants to know this
coming to us from Twitter could the
gravity pull between the planets be so
strong that it would make life
impossible to begin with yeah great
question so there is if you actually
simulate these planetary systems they
are probably gravitationally interacting
and that means to be that's how we know
the masses exactly and that means they
probably have some degree of orbital
eccentricity what that means is you can
have a situation maybe like IO I are on
Jupiter gets tightly heated has all this
volcanism on its surface I'll pull it
pushing and pulling up the gravity we
know that the innermost planet trap is
one probably receives more tidal heating
than IO does the planets exterior to
that probably get less than IO but more
than the earth and the one on the far
outside probably gets less than the
earth as well so in the middle it's a
yeah there is some tidal heating which
could be initiated good or bad it could
be good or bad you know if you don't
have any radio activity to get your
plate tectonics going to have a warm
interior then you need that tidal
heating if you don't then yeah it
depends Alexander McCoy says this with
them having less starlight might forests
of Trappists be darker trees with violet
leaves oh I like the fact that Alexander
is thinking about vegetation on the
planet it's he's and he's already got
down to the autumnal colors that it
might possess but go ahead would that be
I mean that's more for an astrobiologist
that that's a great question
but there is a great video as watching
by physics go and if you know she did a
video about why are plants green and
actually it's remarkable that we still
don't really know they're like ideas as
to why that's true but we don't really
know it's green if the plants are green
that means they reflect the green light
because that's what we see exactly
they're not using it yeah they're not
using the green light but the Sun peeks
its own spectrum and
so the most of the sun's light is
actually in the green window it doesn't
look green because it's it's just about
the same amount of light in all the
colors but yeah that's all good I know
there are some plants which are black or
very dark I mean you've seen them so you
know it's possible the planet could be
covered in those things instead but if
it's it's kind of unclear we don't even
really know why it's happening on the
earth let alone what it's going to be
happening excellent question though well
just interesting even more than the
people cool all right
all right this is our Jun that who says
this all do we how do we know about
their similarity to earth that that's
how do you know I wouldn't buy any real
estate right I mean a lot of astronomers
get really upset when the media keep
calling it earth-like because you don't
know it's earth like oh you know that
it's the size of the earth and it has
and amount of radiation it receives is
roughly the same as the earth ER so
these ones were lucky because we know a
little bit about the mass the error bars
are big the uncertainty is pretty big
but we do know about the mass because
it's a multiple planet system and so
it's it's called the transit timing
technique right because the transits are
a little bit different because of all
the gravitational interactions so we can
use that to to estimate the masses of
some of these planets and the transit is
where it comes in front of the Sun and
and and the light dips okay cool so the
window dips in and then it comes back
out and then we know yeah it's great
well there you have it we're done all
right everything I gotta tell you it was
fascinating this is I've learned more
than I ever thought I would about the
Seven Dwarfs you've been listening to
Startalk all-stars Thank You Chuck nice
for being my comedic co-host always a
pleasure and thank you david kipping for
coming down from Columbia University to
talk to us today this is great friend
thanks for having me I've been your host
Emily rice and stay curious listeners
this is Startalk
[Music]